all right hello everybody uh welcome
back from the lunch break
um so we're kind of going to continue
the day optimization day where we left
off so we covered first order
optimization methods in the morning and
this afternoon I will be covering a high
order optimization methods um it's my
great pleasure to introduce who will be
presenting uh both for an hour now we'll
have a break and there'll be one more uh
one hour talk to close out the day
um uh diksha is a fellow at eth Zurich
um and she's done a number of foundation
works on higher order optimization
methods I think our work has spanned
using it for certain sorts of
combinatorial and graph optimization
problems as well as advancing
optimization Theory based on it it's
part of broader work on optimization and
algorithm design in general and I look
forward to your introduction to higher
order optimization thank you
thank you everyone for coming and thanks
for the introduction
so uh I'm going to the goal of these two
talks is basically to see what can you
do when you know more than just the
first derivative of a function so so
again the goal would be similar to
optimize a function but we would try to
see that what can you do if you have the
additional information or you know
second order derivatives third order
derivatives and other derivatives so I'm
going to use the board so if anyone
can't see or needs me to write larger
please let me know and please talk me
for any questions
okay
so uh let's do a quick recap of what we
did uh in the morning so because we in
the morning we were looking at this
problem so you have to minimize
some function X
and the function was convex so you start
with the convex function and the
constraint set is also convex and what
we knew was you we had a black box so we
had an oracle
that at any point x so you feed it X
and this gave you
f of x and gradient f of x
okay and if we have this then we saw two
things that one was gradient descent and
one was accelerated gradient descent now
let's for the next two talks let's just
only think about smooth functions so by
smooth we mean that the gradient was lip
shits so for the first order smooth we
basically mean that for all X and Y you
had
that the gradient is a Lipschitz
function
so let me call it L1 left sheets because
it's first order
and you had
we had this good so for these kind of
functions we saw that gradient descent
gradient descent gives you uh
free rate of convergence so if you have
k iterations
the function error so the f of x k minus
the optimum this basically decreases as
some
L1
or
sorry over here
and when you use the accelerated version
so that we had accelerated gradient
descent
you could basically do a little bit
better
so we could do
could actually do quadratically better
and we also know that if you only have
access to these two quantities then this
is the best we can do for smooth
functions
okay
so now so these were studied over the
70s and the 80s so between 1970 and 1985
these two methods were developed and the
question still remained what can you do
if suppose you just you also knew the
Hessian so for the second order so uh
over the next few years basically people
were looking at what happens when you
know the Hessian and actually in 2006
uh this was a work by nestorov
we actually we had the first method that
you know given so now the Blackboard
blog so now the model was the oracle
gives you f of x
gradient f of x and also the Hessian at
f of x
so given these so we had the first
method that actually showed convergence
when you're given these and that
convergence was uh much faster obviously
but so yes so the in 2006 nestorov gave
a version of second order gradient
descent
and
that's which is basically called cubic
Newton
or this is also
let's think of it a second order
radiant descent and this showed that the
rate of convergence
oh yes so I missed one thing so again we
are looking at function before I State
the rates we are looking at functions
that are second order smooth so we had
rates here for functions that were first
order smooth so the gradient was
lipsticks but now we want to look at
functions which are the Hessian to be
Ellipsis function so you're looking at
functions that are
second order smooth
and this gives you
this basically means that for any X and
Y
you have
this is less than some L2
and this Norm is the operator norm and
here we'll just deal with euclidean
norms for today okay so for these kind
of functions you can actually do
something that cubic Newton gives you
a rate of convergence that's actually
similar to
accelerated gradient descent
and soon after
in 2008
oh sorry this was nestorov and poliak
okay and in 2008
there was another uh Improvement to this
and this was Again by nestorov
and he gave an algorithm which was
analogous to The Accelerated gradient
descent and he called it accelerated
cubic Newton and that basically gave you
a rate
which was
to be K cubed
okay so uh so until 2008 we heard some
things about uh second order methods for
smooth functions a
extensions to this to let's say so we
then start we can now look at what we
mean by
pH order oracles so before I explain
what we actually mean by these kind of
smoothness and what can you get with
these kind of smoothness let's
first just Define what we mean by path
order oracles
okay good
okay
so now uh as a similar extension you
start with x
and you want to know f of x
gradient f of x
and you know all higher order
derivatives or f of x
and given this and now again we would
look at functions so we looked at L2
smooth but the Hessian was smooth we saw
L1 smooth where the gradient was smooth
so a natural extension is we will look
at functions which are
LP smooth
so that means that the pth order
derivative is Lipschitz
so you want this condition to hold
foreign
what we mean by this Norm
so this Norm basically means that you
want to find
the max
so this is like a pH degree tensor so
you want to find
the maximum of this value
that's that
okay so this is basically an extension
of
let's say the operator Norm to a higher
orders higher order tensors and this is
just the directional derivative of this
along these directions
so this is like an analog of the
operator Norm to these higher order
derivatives and
what I mean by this quantity this is the
directional derivative of directional
derivative yeah
okay so we'll okay so today we'll look
at this these kind of functions
basically and yeah so we have these P
derivatives it's LPS smooth so the pH
derivative is lip
and this is the norm we are working
under
so you may ask that uh how are these
lipsticksness related to or anything the
first order but these are like totally
unrelated like the gradient can be
lipsticks but this may not be true or
this may be lipids and no other
derivative may be smooth but uh like a
simple example is you can just take the
function f of x is X to the P for
example and
DP minus 1 derivative is lip ships but
none of the others are clips
yeah
I think it says
[Applause]
the
last one yes it's not more convenient to
work
it's more convenient yeah
yeah you can work with that but I mean
the way we use these lipsticksness isn't
I'll get to why how we're using this and
in that case it's easier to foreign
all right so this is so one example of a
function which is actually you know
um smooth for all orders of p and that
function is
going to give an example of that
function and that function has actually
helped in many uh combinatorial
optimization problems like you can use
that for modeling Infinity regression
you can use it for Matrix scaling you
can use it for operator scaling and it's
basically a smoothing of infinity
regression which we call the soft Max
function and
let me Define it first
so this is one
[Music]
so as an example
let's see
it's called Soft Max with parameter mu
and this is defined as
so this function is
uh so it is in this paper let me check
which one
oh sorry
thank you yeah
yeah
and there's also one over here
so in this
deep you can actually show that for this
so there's this
theorem by
which proves that this is higher order
smooth for all P so basically it is some
e plus one by
youth order smooth
and yes uh like some computation can
show you if mu is something like Epsilon
by log n then it approximates Infinity
regression to an Epsilon additive error
and
a lot of these Matrix scaling problems
especially there's a few of these Works
actually uh model their things as a soft
Max objective and they try to optimize
over that
okay
good so we do have functions that are
good for all p and for these if you use
some higher order Oracle then maybe you
can do a lot better instead of just
using first order Oracle
okay so in the sense of algorithms for
these higher order smooth problems
so the first algorithms uh are actually
in 2018 2009
and
2019. there were two different works by
one was by base
and one was by nestro
and they gave an analog for gradient
descent to these orders and an analog
for Accelerated gradient design
so for gradient descent you basically
let's say teeth
gradient descent you basically get
something that's
going to ignore all the other terms and
just look at focus on the Epsilon
convergence for now so this goes as
1 over p and
accelerated gradient descent actually
gives you 1 over
so you can go from one over to learn to
the one by P and here you have Epsilon
to the 1 by P plus one and regarding the
optimality of this we'll look at that in
the next lecture where
uh so the short answer is this is not
optimal for p uh it's only so the
extensions of AGD are only optimal for
the first order but for higher orders
it's not and we'll look at the optimal
algorithms in the next part
you also need some kind of lower bound
right so the lower bound is just from
convex City actually even if you recall
in first order AGD you only used
smoothness which is lipstickness of the
gradient and you used convexity and we
didn't really use anything else so here
also we just have this kind of
liquidness
that's sufficient
okay so in this talk will focus on I'll
try to give a proof of this path order
gradient descent
okay
so before we look at that let's see what
does this pH order smoothness actually
give us
so in the first order uh
oh it is that but for the first order
smoothness you basically were able to we
were able to give an upper Bound for the
function so particularly from first
order's boothness
we could say that if a Fung if a
function was first order smooth so you
could write this kind of upper Bound for
the function
um
and gradient descent what it one
interpretation was that you just
minimize this at every point so if you
are at iteration x t you just minimize
this and you move the you minimize this
to get a new point and then your new
iterate is just the
minimization of this upper body so we
want to use the same idea for higher
order things but so from pH order so
let's just look at second order as a
simple example
so when P equals to uh
we basically have oh yeah let's go here
so here for p equals to now I want to do
something with this and see what kind of
upper bound you can get so a simple
integration exercise will give us two
things so the first thing first one set
of integration will give you
uh
so if we just do some integration some
calculus here they first do it once we
get this kind of bond which is some so
what is this saying that you have this
gradient at X then you have some tailor
expansion of this gradient
uh so you have around this point why and
you know this difference is bounded in
some way
and if you do another round of
integration what we would get is
[Music]
if you do one more then you basically
get this
so you can what we see is you're
basically because of this you can bound
any the function at x with a cubic
polynomial essentially
so this second order smoothness gives
you a cubic polynomial as an upper bound
and the same thing translates to uh pH
order smoothness so for p
from LP lipschitzness you can basically
get
for any X and Y you can
so you can bond this by the Taylor
expansion around a point plus some
distance from as Alina alluded to in the
morning that you have this Taylor
expansion under distance term okay
so uh the first algorithm that you would
want to naturally look at is okay so
let's start with some x0
so let's say this is some potential
algorithm start with x0 and you want x k
plus 1 to just be uh
argument
of
so of basically this function
so if I call this function sum
let me call it Omega of
why at
so okay so that so let's say at the
Taylor expansion Center dot x k
and some function of Y
so the algorithm is you just want to
minimize this upper bound and we want to
see how does this converge
so even ask that why is this doing this
any easier minimizing this upper bound
and the short answer is that for p
greater than 2 it's still an open
problem to find efficient ways to
minimize this Oracle but under certain
models which like there's this work by
Iron Arun and group which talks about a
ball Oracle which is essentially some
high order p
uh Oracle that you know solves this and
for Hessian stable functions or like
some good functions you can do this very
efficiently
so okay so it Still Remains open if you
can solve this but we know at least one
fact so nestro when 2019 he proved that
if you reduce this
to actually
minus 1 factorial
instead of P then this upper bound this
is a convex function and once this is
convex at least you know there exists a
solution and how to find it is at least
there exists a unique solution
okay are there any questions
so you make solution which one do you
think
yeah so to make it well defined we
actually use this upper Bond instead of
the
one with P factorial
I think it's just oh if it's strongly if
it's not strongly convex then you can
just pick any of the minimizers
but at least they'll have the same
function as you
so that's okay
we're really in the center I think this
was very insensitive to the constant so
actually the thing is you can use
anything larger than this
and yeah you can use anything larger
than that it doesn't
but yeah this is the minimum you need
for it to be
conviction
okay good so now let's so let me okay
yeah so there's a proof of why this is
convex in the investor of 2019 paper
called implementable tensor methods and
so if you want to look it up you can
look at it but he basically just you
know uses the second derivative of this
and shows that it's the second
derivative of this f of x is p is D so
the other one is kind of around there
[Music]
so now let's actually look at this
gradient descent algorithm
[Music]
inside
so it's known that's not convex for some
functions
yeah I'm not sure about that if it's
known that it's not convex but yet but
we know that for this it's complex
something basic Republic
I don't think that matters actually
and I think you basically when we think
of large tea we usually think of
something like login also
[Music]
yeah I'm not sure if we know
do you have anything correct oh just
I'll repeat what I said to you just like
gradient descent also if you take too
big a step which is the same as too
small a regularizer eventually it'll
diverge rather than convert
like meeting the regularizer to be at
least something that seems like a Common
Thread now the the fact that it's not
convex in the certain regime needs to be
larger that isn't interested same thing
though I don't know the answer to your
wonderful question about this recipe
let's go for any smooth theater smooth
and convex function
okay okay
now let's see
sorry I was only there are many
interesting things like even and oddness
when you talk about implementability
that's why but uh when it comes to just
a method working
good
oh yeah so let me Define
let me Define this to just be the first
feed I'm going to just use a small okay
I'm just going to use this to denote
detail or expansion
payload expansion around X
this is the pH order Taylor expansion
around X Plus
[Music]
okay
and the algorithm is
called
so let's just think of unconstrained
problems and not worry about the
constraints at this point
and
this is yes
this is the algorithm and let's see how
to analyze this
okay
right so the analysis is actually
surprisingly not very difficult and it
essentially needs two tools and the
first one is okay
okay
[Music]
so we want to prove
this is again
master of 2019
and
[Music]
12 K greater than 0 you want to prove
Okay so
this is what we want to prove so let's
ignore all the constants let's just
think of this as some radius so let's
replace it with some
so it's inside some big box and we'll
just look at this so you just have this
K to the P essentially the bottom so if
you want to go down to Epsilon it
becomes thing like 1 by Epsilon to the
one by P
okay so we want to prove this and in
order to do so the first key thing we
want we will show is that uh which is
the first thing we want to show is we
want to characterize what is this thing
at K plus 1 do
so
we have this that f of x k plus 1 is
basically less than
if you look at this
at any point this f of x k plus 1 is
less than the minimizer of the function
at some ovate
sorry
K plus 1 it's basically less than the
minimizer of the function plus this is
like some small regularization so if you
are actually close to the optimum even
in distance this would be very small so
yeah
you're within like some pound to the
optimizer
and a very quick proof of this is just
yeah right so the solutions that you're
actually getting by minimizing this
upper bound is
in some way not too far from these and
to see this let's
oh I also forgot to mention one fact
that
from this uh
because we we also know that f of x
K plus 1 is less than
okay
basically so you know that f of x k plus
1 is less than this
and this is again proven in this paper
okay good so
given this uh and this is actually easy
to see so we start with using that fact
so you start with we know that f of x
okay plus one is less than
and if we recall this is just the Taylor
expansion with some regularization
parameter
and this
we know is
minimum
minimum over X of this one
so we know this is true just by
definitions
and uh
if we expand this
so this is just again the minimum
over X of this Taylor expansion
[Music]
so this is just expanding this so we
know this and now we can use
a bound from pH order smoothness which
is
okay so uh the bound on you know you
could bounce any function by the Taylor
expansion plus the regularization so
use that and this would give us
it follows from smoothness and you just
get
plus some
some other some constants let's not go
over about them and you get this
so the only thing we use here is the
definition of what we are minimizing and
create order smoothness
and now we'll use this to actually
approve our
so okay so we want to prove this the
easiest ways we'll just use induction
so for k equals one
so let's use
induction
k equals one
[Music]
we we start with this
so this is always true
and we know that
X1 is at most
okay so this is just using
and then this you can just click them in
within these things and you just get f
of x
Star Plus
I feel like I still don't understand the
proof of Lemma a actually so how did you
do the last transition again it seems
that you you replaced this uh t u the F
and oh so I replaced this t with f plus
some constant times this term
uh-huh
right but then in the statement of
dilemma the constant is LP over perfect
yeah so there's one more constant that
adds up to this ah and this is p minus
one yeah
maybe I messed up the constants but
basically you get some constant here
from the definition of this and then you
get another constant from here and that
adds up to
[Music]
I'm so confused because this
so so somehow one thing I
can't reconcile is the following T is an
upper bound on F so in this Lemma the
right hand side
could it seems generally be
significantly smaller than the minimum
of the T
ah but it's also you also have this so
it's
it's an upper bound on okay good that's
a good question and one second
yeah
I think T is an approximation of f after
something involving the distance between
the center and X right this is
like it's like an absolute value the
lower bound is only convexity for one
when you go past one you can bound how
far it is but it's not necessarily above
okay two it's still above because I see
three is where it gets funny yes okay
so in reality
okay so I'll just repeat it to make sure
I understand uh
is it right that in reality this t plus
a constant times the movement cost uh
this actually sandwiches
on both sides yes it's lower and an
upper bound the movement part
may not really be a lower Bound for this
so I always I I don't quite see how this
follows without a lower bound right it's
just that the right hand side it's a
minimum of f of Y over all Y and if T
only provides an upper bound I'm just
not quite
succeeding and imagining how we get it
right
okay uh
okay so to work with t but maybe we can
take off finals yeah we can take it
offline I can actually assure you if it
comes like you have this F of Y minus so
scalar expansion absolute value is upper
bounded by this quantity
that's an upper end yeah yeah
it is the absolute value of the
difference is founded by the absolute
value
expansion okay
yeah so we were showing this so far so
if you want to use induction so for
people it's one we just use Lemma a and
let's see minimizer
and uh
yeah
so this can just be
huh
this can just be an upper bound on this
side
on the diameter of the constraint side
okay
so this is what we want for k equals one
so now let's do the a similar thing for
so what we really want to show next is
if you want to show it for K you want to
show that uh the distance to the optimum
at iteration K plus 1 how is it uh how
much is it lower than the distance to
the optimum ID iteration k
and so if you show for K greater than
one let's again start with this so you
have
[Music]
with this again
okay so the minimization is overall
space I'm going to so this is less than
you're doing the minimization over let's
say some
and I'm changing y to be uh
the minimization over all Space versus
now I'm just optimizing over this line
joining x k and extra
and
this gives us LP
okay
so
so we basically can reduce this to a
minimization along between x k and the
optimum and now this is a problem in
Alpha scalar and minimize it at least we
let's just take the derivative and set
it to zero and let's hope that that lies
between 0 and 1 and then we're good so
uh just setting so just looking at this
function taking derivative setting it to
zero let's say that gives you Alpha star
oh actually let me do one more step
before that so I'm going to use
convexity of f first
so this is the same as
uh
okay yeah now this is much easier to
minimize I just use convexity to split
this
and now minimizing this over Alpha you
just get Alpha star that's
equal to
let's say
okay this is the optimum Alpha for this
just gives you something like this and
this we know is at least greater than
zero ah
and if we want to show whether this is
less than one
uh I claim that this is also less than
one
so you want to see that
okay so I'm going to claim that this is
less than one
and uh
uh okay maybe I'll skip that for now in
the interest of time so I can see yeah
yeah R is let's say we have a convex set
R is just some radius for the connection
ah okay good uh
or let me say that R is rather it's an
upper bound on x 1 minus x x minus X
star for all the iterates X
okay good so we want Alpha star less
than one and I claim that this is less
than one and I'm going to skip that for
now
okay so given this we resubstitute this
back
yep
just checking is that lesson one for all
iterates or just like after the first
iterate oh it is after the first year
okay the first though yeah the first it
created yeah it's all subsequent ones
yeah
let's go forward
okay so if I resubstitute back Alpha
star back
so what we would get is
of x k plus one
x k minus
foreign
skipping a bunch of calculations here
but what you can but just by
substituting this back and doing some
algebra you can get that this function
at K plus 1 has actually decreased in
some way
and
if I do something more you can actually
say that the distance
if I just subtract and X star
can get this
[Music]
y minus
when somewhere it's decreasing but we
call that this Alpha star actually
depends on this difference
so if you replug that and let me just
call this
e difference at K plus 1 and this is the
difference okay
so what we would really get is
minus some constant
this is just putting these things back
in and you get this
and the way to go from this so now we
want to use this to show something about
how many iterates you can get and a
sketch of how to do this
is
[Music]
um
let me just ignore this constant here
because Let's ignore all the p l p r
dependencies and only focus on how you
can get the dependence on K and if you
want to use this the easy way is your
I'm going to look at this
this difference
so I'm going to use look at this
difference and
this can be
a
just shifting things around and
further uh
okay I can further write this as
okay
we're just doing some algebra you can
add and subtract some terms and this is
exactly equal to this and now we want to
use this bound that we know
from here
at that point so this just implies that
is yeah
[Music]
yeah I just left the concept
yeah yeah
no no there's some constants yeah
okay
yeah this just implies that this is
oh sorry so Delta k
we just use this bound over there and
some more simplification will actually
give us
that this can be
this is greater than
[Music]
and so it will give us some ratio like
this and I claim that this is greater
than 1.
I mean we claim that this the distance
keeps decreasing so you can just say
this is greater than one
so what we
so once you have that this difference is
greater than 1 by P you can induct over
this difference and in the end
okay so this part is good and
so we're almost done
uh
yeah but then like when you're like near
me
I mean that's exactly what it's giving
you is this maybe this is easier to see
we had this
yeah so I mean this just gives us
something like
that so this is just something like
eight times
K by take K minus 1 by P plus
I mean
your repair is small somehow I was
hoping that your approximation would be
good enough that you are
products like Europe like it doesn't get
much slower than the beginning
they're kind of great for you
yeah
when you're super close your minimizer
that's like that gives you like a very
small process
close
so it's an extension of variant
messenger
once you have this this gives us
we can just use something
okay initial error and you can basically
see that Delta K plus 1 is something
like
some constants problem dependent
constants and you just get this k
okay
so uh we basically you can see that if
you just use these higher derivatives
you were able to get some improvement
over the first uh
first order cases and
I'm going to stop here for this one and
uh
you can come back and see how to
accelerate these algorithms in the next
one but I am happy to take questions
after
[Applause]
you questions
[Music]
it's unrelated but if you only have a
zero order Oracle then you still do
gradient descent under some reasonable
assumptions or if you only have
something that gives you f of x yes
I mean then what would you mean by
gradient descent you can still
approximate gradient right oh so you
have some so you're trying to say is it
that you have some approximation to the
gradient and no but I mean you can just
by definition you can approximate
ingredients
not just small enough right
um yeah I don't think I get your
question
so yes there is work on zeroth order
optimization there's actually there's
like different work on actually like
what if you have second order
lipsticksness but only a gradient Oracle
or you have like radiant lipstickness
and only a zeroth order Oracle also and
what if you have no all sorts of
variants of this are are studied I think
there are a lot of interesting stories
to tell depending on which settings you
have but yeah
I think
function
thank you
I'm happy to discuss this episode any
other questions
you want to say a little bit about what
will happen after the break oh yeah
so this was an extension of gradient
descent uh we will the extension of
accelerated gradient descent does not
give us the optimal rate so we'll see
how that looks like at least the
algorithm and we'll see what the
algorithm is that gives you the optimal
rate and we'll look at that algorithm
but uh the optimal algorithm has
actually proven very useful in giving uh
some of the optimal higher order
algorithms for uh let's say regression
problems even you can directly get ckm
ST Math flow from it and there have been
many applications but those applications
we might have to take offline because
the but I'll at least give a sense of
what the algorithm is like
or ckmsd is this uh 2010 work by
Cristiano Kellner badri Spillman and
Tang that accelerates Max flow using it
so yeah yeah good yeah
thank you again
[Applause]
all right so we'll have a break now
until 3